♫ In New York ♫
♫ Concrete jungle, wet dream tomato ♫
♫ I see a little silhouetto of a man ♫
♫ Got a moose, got a moose ♫
♫ Will you do the fandango? ♫
- ♫ Thunderbolt ♫
- What's a fandango?
- It's a movie service.
- Yeah, okay.
- My neck hurts.
- ♫ Secret asian man, secret asian man ♫
- ♫ Fu-fu-fu-fuck her face ♫
♫ Fu-fu-fu-fuck her face ♫
- No, stop that.
- ♫ Fu-fu-fu-fuck her face ♫
♫ Fu-fu-fu-fuck her face ♫
- ♫ There's a bathroom on the right ♫
- Pull over!
- Yeah, we've been driving
for like three hours.
- I told you we're not stopping.
- You're not my real dad!!
- I wish that I wasn't.
- I miss mom.
- ♫ I'm into having sex ♫
♫ I ain't into makin' love ♫
♫ So come gimme a hug, ♫
♫ If you into gettin' drugged ♫
- What?
- You nasty, some Cosby shit.
- ♫ Here we are now in containers ♫
♫ Avocado, a potato, yeah. ♫
- ♫ Lucky that my breasts
are small and humble ♫
♫ So you don't confuse them with muffins ♫
♫ Le ro lo le lo le ♫
Chris?
Chris, stop eating my muffins.
- I haven't had breakfast, I'm hungry.
- ♫ Dirty deeds ♫
- ♫ Underneath, done with
sheep, thunderchief ♫
- No, no it's thunderchief, guys.
- It's done with sheep.
- It's underneath.
- It's actually hunger Keith.
- Get out of here Keith.
- Get out of our video.
- You can't be in every video Keith.
- I need a band, I need a band.
- Get out of here!
- ♫ You're gonna miss me when I'm gone ♫
♫ You're gonna miss me by my walk ♫
♫ You're gonna miss me by my taco. ♫
♫ You're gonna miss when I'm gone. ♫
- ♫ It's not fair to deny me ♫
♫ of the cross-eyed bear
that you gave to me ♫
♫ You, you, you, ought a know. ♫
- ♫ Blinded by the light ♫
♫ Wrapped like a douche,
another runner in the night ♫
- (coughs) Fuck, Chris.
- [Chris] ♫ Yeah, snap yo bagels. ♫
♫ Do ya stare ♫
♫ You can do it all by yo self ♫
- ♫ Hold me closer Tony Danza ♫
- There's only one thing
that would make this better.
- ♫ It's gonna, gonna,
gonna, gonna, gonna. ♫
- ♫ It's gonna be May. ♫
- ♫ Actin' funny, but I don't know why ♫
- ♫ 'Scuse me while I kiss this guy ♫
- ♫ Darlin' you're so great ♫
♫ I can't wait for you to ovulate. ♫
- What?
- Sexual.
- Yeah gross Eugene, Allison
let's get out of here.
- Oh, you smell like a douche.
- What like Axe Body Spray?
- No like an actual douche.
- ♫ You can dance, you can die. ♫
- ♫ Having the time of your life. ♫
- (Chris choking)
♫ Whoo-oo-oo, see that
girl, watch that scene ♫
♫ Kicking the dancing queen ♫
- [Chris] I'm still -
- [Chris] I'm still alive.